It will be just for two
years of the president.
Well, we are looking at the position of the president against him.
This is the Ukrainian people
showing that now we are the
companies, they are the Zanad district, our own lands, our
existing western countries, I will come and
cooperate with the
war.  there
was a
royal protest from afar on her but still
we are dedicated to a
little weight and the bottom of the trade flag
or
funeral of Ukraine ideal meaning And once again
I say the
official Ukraine sang to the one in which the balls
samples of the question were received
correctly on those 100 and the game they can
our paid
Volodymyr
and  private military
billion
adaptocidovshchyna oblast
47 minutes something to eliminate such techniques or
connection
officers two million years old Surazh
green
players players made all the
paperwork
and at the expense of
Why did it
develop asistential of Ukraine and and such
changes persons Thus
first but for all the facts the idea is a holy
year  eh, which gives about Putin in the frame and
on the primordial spirals and her on the state of who
match Montenegro Tyutyu But isn’t the power
much better than them in fact the workers
or it’s already his materials
they Zelenskyy yesterday not UPA to you
[music]
Ukrainian firms
political organizations  of the president
[music]
specific projects to learn
ring-shaped onicatives were built by our
little and must this Tomashchenko came to
Ukraine more precisely there were many opportunities
to investigate his brother but to
change to a patriotic one so wait for
all the parents of the connectivity of the schoolboy of the
nuclear administration and leather
sports and it is also a technique of Artek to do
our  in Ukraine, the labors of my
mother's years, the potentials as a culture
have collected money
[music]
the situation in Ukraine
will develop and about a safe universe of
worms will bring to cook on e-e the teacher of the
institutionalization of the support of Ukraine with his
problems, take into the budget
will record the obedience of Ukraine and the prosecutor's office
miantigraph efina or not  Prostitutes are
newer 500 million hryvnias and the Czech
Vika is sick before the theater. Is it correct or is
alcohol the third million?
This is the position of Ukraine in all its districts, or
in the morning, communal exactly the leading
mileage in one Denmark, councils, e-e, NATO
Ukraine and Ukraine Ukraine
[music] the
matter is clear in the weather game
NATO stands for corruption training, and in March,
your guys are valuable.
Is there any participation in Ukraine at all?
All the structures of NATO are
anti-gam and so dangerous to the
general regional waters of the
Romanian Poroshenko.
about the labor protection of sports absorbed by
age in Ukraine and Russia Feromatov
fishes were the Christmas tree of law
[music]
Samodyna architecture - this is the structure that Ukraine promises
to prepare for my putting state
Other not only organizations I will
answer you on each became such a temple the
source of human freedoms
results Thank
you very much the president
actually to  us for your words, the words are
strange and at the same time very strong statements of
Mr. President, dear
journalists, and dear honest
Ukrainian delegation in Prague, first of
all, I want to thank you now, the
amount of willful support will change, and it is very
symbolic that this Czech Republic began on such a
day, the day of remembrance I  became a
national hero of the Czech Republic and everyone who
appreciates him is worthy of Czech participation.
Courage is really felt, it
is felt in defense
and politics in everything. What we all do together
for the sake of our youth of our Europe. I want to
especially thank you, Mr. President.
Who helps our people,
our Ukrainian children who received
protection in your country from this
really terrible war, all of us in Ukraine
dream of the day when we can
guarantee the safety of all our people, and
therefore the opportunity to return
home. I am grateful to the Czech Republic for providing weapons
for Ukraine, sanctions against Russia,
supporting our membership in the
European Union,
fourthly,
your people really help
us to wish for victory, the
agenda of our negotiations, the Czech Republic is
completely clear in principle, the president
simply said,
confirms the first - this is our common
security and cooperation for the sake of the defense service, they
talked about a
possible response to Russia's creation of a
terrorist network, in particular, to the situation
at the Zaporizhzhia nuclear power plant, Russia deserves
increased sanctions  against her, they
discussed her existing spread of
Russian propaganda, which unfortunately still
has an influence in Europe and in the Czech Republic and in other
European countries. It is obvious that
Russia has a destructive influence.
efforts in
relations with third countries in the Czech Republic
can help to attract countries of the
global level to our joint
peace efforts, in particular the implementation of
formulas Today I informed Mr.
President of the Czech Republic against how we already
involve many partners We have started
this work I believe that it is
successful
Africa Latin America Asia but we  we
need help in the direction We
still have to work on the
third strengthening of our allies before
all of NATO, it is very important that the Czech Republic does not
look back at the brain or anyone else for
its political decisions
as independent
independent as brave brave We
understand each other perfectly and it will be
correct if such an understanding is
reflected in concrete meaning
not in empty words but in concrete
meaning in Vinnytsia, I want to thank you for the
beginning of
our team's visit, for the beginning of our
negotiations, I thank you for the financial attention, and
separately I want to thank you for every
Ukrainian right
to express the
flag
at the
gates of your people in your hands, and this  very convenient
Thank you very much
this is a reality this is a radiator Thank you for
such a reality for such an attitude towards
Ukraine Kudos to Ukraine
to President Volodymyr Zelenskyi
Mr. President those who remain in the
army exactly to the name what are the hopes for
these same
in particular in terms of Ukraine receiving the
invitation what wording was
perfect and Kyiv  What do you think?
Well,
the answer to your question is, in principle,
everything is a question. What would be ideal
for us to be invited?
What wording is required for the invitation? We
just need to invite.  of the
Alliance partners, some are going to Moscow,
some are afraid of Russia. Although I believe that this is
such a moment, such a great chance to show
courage in the Alliance and the Minsk
Security Council. Nevertheless, we are talking about whether to
signal some specific things in
this direction,
we need this motivation, we need
honor in  our relations, but we
understand that other very important things will be discussed and resolved on the sidelines of the summit. The
discussion of
certain packages of defense support is
important to us. We live in the future, the future
is victory, but at the same time, we must
be realistic because we are in a war and
we will survive.  today, what we have on the
training ground, what is lacking, and therefore Avzhezh
himself gives the opportunity to discuss and
agree on the support of partners with
additional packages of Ukrainian soldiers of
Luhansk
and
[music]
in the
lessons,
you mean the liberation of a group of
citizens of Ukraine who communicate in
Russian, in the process I am
investigating  can I misunderstand
about this question,
we
see your eyes
like this And you see It is also important and
important that you see mine And Putin
only hears her, does not see and believes himself
nonsense But nevertheless I want to
tell you to explain
Russia
from the moment of the full-scale invasion
in most of them the Russian-speaking people were killed by the
war in the East,
there were,
in principle, a lot of people who
spoke Russian,
and in the
southern part of Ukraine there, people
speak Ukrainian and Russian,
we had no problem
Kharkiv also spoke Ukrainian and
Russian,
all the
regions that I told you about
are attacked daily  the Russian
Federation and why Russia does not have any
support because the main gas in Russia is that
they
support people who speak
Russian multiplied by zero because they
killed killed most of the people who
spoke Russian Because they also
destroyed
those cities completely you know Mariupol
Bakhmut you were there you understand  there are
simply no such places there,
adult children are killed and completely beaten, this is the population,
many people who spoke Russian are
switching to Ukrainian because of this, there
has never been such unity in Ukraine, they are
simply switching Why Because they can no
longer
hate these, this is what is happening,
this is an important moment
because we are saying
where to squeeze through the language, this has
never happened in Ukraine as far as
partners are concerned, I have a lot of meetings,
important signals, I really wanted to
thank the partners and the countries that
help us, Bulgaria, the
leadership of the state, first of all, the government, for
today, three very important
decisions have been made  in the Parliament of Bulgaria
regarding NATO support and there will be a serious
defense package that we really
need and also an energy solution
that we expected. As for the Czech Republic, I
told you why I am here and I expect
support.
We have support.  to
our friends and not
only to our partners, it is difficult to pay more attention to our friends
because of the war, but I
found this opportunity. I think it is
very correct regarding
Turkey, which you said
before us.
to put pressure on the
Russian Federation politically, not only on the
battlefield, but to put pressure together, we have several
issues, grainy initiatives, we have a very
important issue, support for Ukraine, NATO, we
have an exchange of prisoners, etc., many things
we will talk about and I believe we will
have agreements with the President of
Turkey
that we are taking the
initiative, now we do
n't have a quick one here, it's a
fact But nevertheless We
are moving forward and not moving backward like
Russia and that's why I see this work Thank
you [music] questions for the President Pavlovy
continued
if I'm not mistaken, you were the first leader
and with the military experts who said in
the winter that Ukraine has such a state, this is a
small contour. What do you think
now, and the question to the president
remains very tense for three days, we
said that the transfer of the station from the Ukrainians
in Ukraine should have been published through an
intermediary or with the help of many
countries, what could they write  of your
experts Well, do you already know the
store's reaction to this proposal and in which countries they
could see it
[music] it is
dangerous, we know that there are contacts of
stores in the Russian Federation Well, they
will work, we will be grateful if there is a
positive in this
dangerous dangerous very dangerous
stories there is no more to add  of the
mood of the
Alexandrov days,
I was waiting for
all the events that would
take place.
I understand
that for sure
and it is very painful if it was
taken away by a war, a
murderer was stolen or people were killed, and a
place for happiness, and for the first and for the second
World, I understand
how positive it is that you do not have that
person,
even this weapon. To be honest, life is
a lot,
but you have to fight  to return the child
fight absolutely everything and when I tell
everyone This is a question for me Because I want to
remove the responsibility of the representatives of
our
institutes not for us a sign of the state No, but everyone
has to fight for children And this is our
future, we have opened a suitable center, there are
specialists who are currently working there  of different
children who we really think are
deported by force, we think we
find them, journalists help a little
here, I turn to
journalists, journalists, Ternopil, we
need to work more in this direction,
you can find this information sometimes
faster than the relevant authorities. I talk
to various partners with leaders to
helped in the direction of the deportation of the children,
the return, I spoke with the Pope,
among other things. This is one of the issues where the temptation is to
help put pressure on the Russian Federation,
and that is why it is so important that this issue
will definitely be discussed and
decided on the platform of the
formula,
we return, we return the children, not much yet,
but
this is a very serious challenge as far as NATO is concerned,
I said that we need
some kind of signal
or that Ukraine will be in the alliance, not
that the door is open for us, that is not
enough But that Ukraine will be, but the
Alliance is going no matter what, it
just seems to me that  NATO must
win, you understand. Today we
see Sweden. The Alliance has not
yet found a common signal regarding
Sweden and therefore Sweden is not yet in NATO and
the decision.
There is no
invitation in one or another form of Ukraine
yet. There is also no
reason for the success of
the Alliance. And it seems to me that the world  our
society and Russia must also
demonstrate the strength and unity of the
state
it represents